Big O notation is used to classify algorithms
based on how fast they grow or decline. It is
very important to understand for many types of
programming, Giorgio Thompson does a great job of
breaking down big O notation in this course. Hey,
what's up everybody and welcome to my mini series
on big O notation. And this mini series, you'll
learn everything that you need to know about big
O notation and how you can use it to improve
your ability to create efficient algorithms.
I'll use whiteboard illustrations to help you
visualize and understand concepts followed by
coding tutorials that you can follow along with
to further solidify your grasp of the concepts
will answer the question what is big O notation?
And why is it useful? So what is big O notation?
Big O notation is used to analyze the efficiency
of an algorithm as its input approaches infinity,
which means that as the size of the input to the
algorithm grows, how drastically do the space or
time requirements grow with it. For example,
let's say that we have a dentist and she takes
30 minutes to treat one patient. As her line of
patients increases, the time that it takes for her
to treat all of the patients will scale linearly
with the number of patients waiting in line.
This is because it always takes her a constant
amount of time to treat each individual patient
which is 30 minutes. This gives us a general
understanding of how long our dentist would
take to treat 10 patients 20 patients or even
100,000 patients. This is because since we
know that the dentist takes a constant amount of
time, which is 30 minutes to treat each patient,
we can always calculate the time it would take for
her to treat any number of patients by multiplying
the number of patients times 30 minutes. With this
in mind, we can categorize her efficiency as being
linear. Or as we would say in Big O terms big O
of n, where n is equal to the number of patients
the time that it takes for her to finish her
work scales linearly or proportionally with the
number of patients, we use the same technique
to determine the efficiency of algorithms,
we can get a general idea of how functions
time efficiency scales by categorizing a given
functions efficiency the same way that
we categorize the dentist's efficiency.
Let's create an easily comprehensible
function that scales similarly to the dentist.
So this function is in the same linear category
as our dentist, let's step through it and find
out why. To start the input to our function
is an array with seven items inside of it.
For each of those items, we will log this
expression which multiplies 1000 times 100,000.
Now don't let these large numbers for you, it will
always take the same amount of time to multiply
1000 times 100,000. Therefore this line of code
takes constant time. Which brings me to a very
important point, when considering the efficiency
of a function. These lines that take constant time
do not matter. Well, at least for our purposes,
they don't. This is because if our array were
some crazy length, like 200 million, changing this
expression to something simpler, like one plus one
would have a negligible effect on the efficiency
of the function as a whole, we'd still need to
iterate through 200 million items in an array.
In fact, even if the function looked like this,
we would still ignore all of these constants
and say that this function scales linearly or
is big O of n. Similarly, if we think back to
our dentist example, we see that she took 30
minutes per patient. But even if she took three
hours per patient, the amount of time it takes
her to see all of her patients will still scale
linearly. This can be difficult to grasp at first,
but it starts to make sense over time. So in the
last slide, there was a lot of talk about ignoring
the constants. But what exactly is a constant? A
constant is any step that doesn't scale with the
input to the function. For example, the time to
evaluate this expression does not change with the
input because both 101,000 are constants. That is,
these values are always the same, this expression
always results in the same value. And it always
takes the same amount of time or constant time
to return the same result. Just like we use big O
of n to describe linear functions. We also have a
big O name for constant algorithms, which is
big O of one. A good way to think about it is
every line of code is actually a function in and
of itself, which is actually true. For example,
let's reintroduce this function. So this line
of code is the reason why the entire linear func
function is O of n because as you can see as the
size of n increases the number of iterations that
the for loop must traverse increases as well. But
let's take this second line into consideration.
Let's for one second pretend that we have a
function that contains only this line. Now as you
can see, with this function, we pass in an array,
but the function does nothing with the array.
The only operation within the function is constant
because it doesn't scale with any input. So
regardless of how large of an array is passed to
this function, This line always produces the same
result. And this is the only line in the function.
So therefore, this entire function is over one.
But wait. In this function, we have multiple
lines that are over one yet we still prioritize
the line that is O of n and ignore the O of
one operations. Why is this? Well, this brings
us to our last important note, in bego, we have a
growth hierarchy, which looks something like this.
Now, don't panic, you don't need to understand all
of these just yet. So let's only pay attention to
the ones relevant to this video, or even an old
one. We'll learn about the other ones in following
videos for this series. This chart shows the
efficiency categories in order from good to bad.
That is to say that this first case of one is the
best case. And this last one is the worst case. In
big O notation, when determining the efficiency of
an algorithm, we only care about the worst case.
So that means that the worst case where the
highest order operation trumps the operations
that have better performance. So if we add the
performance of all of these lines up, like so
all of the lines of code that are o of
one get cancelled out because oh Vin is
the worst performing or highest order part of
the function. And this, ladies and gentlemen,
is why we ignore constants, because we're actually
just eliminating the non dominant items. Because
as a functions, input moves towards infinity,
constants become less and less significant.
So to recap, when evaluating an algorithms
efficiency, we must take into consideration
the efficiency of each step within the algorithm,
we then find the highest order step, or the step
that has the worst performance, and prioritize
it over all of the better performing steps,
steps that are constant, or that are over one
or as good as it gets in terms of efficiency.
So we always ignore them, unless the
entirety of the function is constant,
or o of one. And in that case, we would
categorize the entire function as constant
or o of one. And that Ladies and gentlemen,
is your answer to what is big O notation.
Okay, so to understand O of n square, we're going
to need to take the function into consideration
in the function will look something like this. So
what this function is doing is it's going to take
in a number in and it's going to iterate through
this for loop starting with the number zero
all the way up until the number in and
for every iteration of this top for loop,
we're also going to loop through this
nested for loop. And this nested for loop
is doing the exact same thing that this for loop
is doing. It's iterating through every number,
starting with zero up until the number in and
within this nested for loop, we're console logging
the coordinates for a sell within a matrix. But
to make things clear, instead of illustrating a
console log of the index i and j, I'm just going
to draw a square where these coordinates should be
for every iteration of this nested for loop. So
if it sounds confusing, just try to bear with me,
I promise it'll become clear. Okay, so let's say
for example, that we call the square function with
the number four. So that means that we're going
to iterate through this top for loop starting with
starting from zero, and then we're going to
iterate all the way up until I is no longer
less than four, once I becomes equal to four,
then we will stop the iteration. And then that's
only for this top for the for each iteration of
this actual for loop, then we're going to loop
through the entirety of this nested for loop and
do this console log. And instead of logging the
coordinates, like I said, we'll draw a square
where the coordinates would be, so you guys can
visualize this better. So let's go ahead and get
started. So for the first iteration, is going to
equal zero, and then we move on into this nested
for loop. And then we're going to iterate through
the entirety of this nested for loop. So right
now i and j are zero, so i and j are both zero.
So we're currently at the first iteration of this
for loop in the first iteration of this for loop,
and we'll draw a square and then we move up one
iteration of this for loop, so j becomes one and
we'll draw another square. And then j becomes two,
it will draw another square and then j becomes
three, and we'll draw another square and now j is
four. And since j is four, that means that j is no
longer less than n, because n is four, and j is
four, and n is four. So j, and n are now equal,
so will no longer iterate through this for loop.
So now we go back up to this for loop. And now
I is equal to one, so i is equal to one, and
j is equal to zero, so we'll draw a square and
then i is equal to one is in j is equal to one
so we'll draw a square and then i is equal to
one and j is equal to two. So draw a square and
is equal to one and j is equal to three, it will
draw a square. And now back to this top for loop
again, because j and n are now equal, we're back
up to this top for loop again, now i is equal to
two, so i is equal to two, and j is equal to zero,
so we'll draw a square and then i is equal to
two, and j is equal to one, so we'll draw a square
and i is equal to two, and j is equal to two.
So we'll draw a square and i is equal to two,
and j is equal to three, so we'll draw a square
and then now j is equal to four, which is our in,
so will no longer iterate through this nested
for loop, and we move back up to the top of this
for loop, now, i is equal to three, i is equal to
three at this point, and j is equal to zero again,
so we'll draw square is equal to three and j is
equal to one. So we'll draw a square j is equal to
two, j is equal to three. And then j is equal to
four. So we no longer iterate through this nested
for loop. And at this point, our i is now equal to
four and our n is also equal to four. And we only
iterate through this top for loop as long as r is
less than in but our eyes now equal to our in. So
now we stop iterating through this top four loop.
And what we're left with is this matrix here. And
the reason why I said that these are coordinates
for cells within a matrix is because this here
is a matrix. And these are rows. And these
are columns. So we can look
at AI, as being our column.
And then we can look at j is being row. So for
each iteration 0123 of our column, we also have an
iteration for row 0123. So coordinates being zero,
and zero, were the coordinates for this square,
and then zero and one are the coordinates for this
square, and zero, and two are the coordinates for
this square, and so on, and so forth. So what does
all this have to do with oben square? Well, hey,
just one quick interruption. If you are finding
this video helpful, or it's bringing you to some
type of understanding, please take the time
to like and subscribe. If we think about it,
this is a square matrix, that is each side will
be of the same length. And by length, I mean 1234.
This is of length four, and 1234. And this is of
length four, and to find the area of a square,
we just need to multiply the
length of one side by itself,
because every side of a square is of the
same length. So if this were a rectangle,
we would multiply the width times the height, but
for square, we can just multiply by itself because
the width and the height will be the same
length. So to get the area of this square,
we're just going to multiply four times four,
four times four. And that's going
to equal the number of cells
within this matrix, which also happens to be the
number of times that we had to perform this code,
which is four times four is 16. And four
times four is the same thing as four square.
So O of n square, our n is actually four.
And that is why typically functions with nested
for loops, like a for loop and a for loop nested
within it like this function is considered
over in square. I hope that makes sense.
Okay, so to understand all of in queue, let's take
a function into consideration. This cube function
takes in an argument in which is a number. And
it's going to iterate through this for loop and
for every iteration of this for loop is going to
iterate through the entirety of this for loop. And
for every iteration of this for loop, we will need
to iterate through the entirety of this for loop.
And I'm going to have to apologize ahead of
time for my disappointing drawing skills.
But to illustrate this, I'm actually going
to have to draw three dimensional shapes,
which is not something that I'm entirely good
at But anyways, for now, let's just ignore this
image. For now. Let's focus on this function.
So for the top level for We're going to be
iterating up until in. So
if we pass the number four
to our cube function, we'll end up here
at this first for loop. And we're going
to iterate starting from zero all the way up until
n, which is four. So let's get started. So for our
first iteration of this top level for loop, I is
going to be zero. Now for all the in cube, we're
adding in additional nested for loop. So there's
no longer just a row and a column. Now we have
rows, columns. And we also have this third
dimension here, which we'll just call height.
So we have the columns that go in this direction,
the rows that go in this direction, and the height
that go in this direction. So at this point,
we're working with a three dimensional array,
it's no longer a two dimensional array. And it's
the same concept. So it's not as difficult as it
seems, we're going to draw it out now. So we
would start with this initial for loop, and is
going to start off as zero, right. And we'll say
that this initial for loop is representative of
our columns. So we can actually go ahead and write
these numbers out just so you guys can see. So
we'll say that when I zero, this column is zero.
When I is one, we're talking about this column.
When I say two, we're talking about this column,
and one is three, we're talking about this column.
And of course, once I becomes four, we're
no longer going to iterate through this for
loop because I is then no longer less than
n, which is four, it will be equal to four.
And we can say the same thing for the rows.
So we would say that row zero would be here,
row one would be here, row two would be here,
and row three would be here. Now I apologize
if this is difficult for you to see, it's three
dimensional. So it's not really easy to draw this,
but I hope that you guys can visualize what
I'm trying to say. And then the same thing
for the height, the height would be represented by
this for loop here. So okay, and let's actually,
I'm sorry, I should, I should actually just name
these by the letter that we're using in the actual
function. So instead of calling this height,
we'll call this K. Because it's representative,
this this for loop is represented as representing
k here, so we'll just call this k as well.
And instead of calling this columns, we'll
call it AI. And instead of calling this rose,
we'll call it J. So for every iteration of this
for loop, we're going to be moving up this k
axis. So if we were to write in what the index
is for K, it's going to kind of be hard to
see right now. But it will be 012. And
three, so let's try to draw this out.
So let's do this step by step
for a little bit to get you guys
understanding what's happening. So for this first
iteration of this top level for loop, is going to
be equal to zero. So that means that I, this line,
we're going to be here at the zero index of I.
And then for this nested for loop, J is also going
to be equal to zero. So j is here. And we're going
to be at zero here. So we're still going to be
here. And for K as well, this for loop here.
This x is here, we're also going to be at zero,
which is here. So we're still going to be here.
So instead of console logging these coordinates,
we'll just draw a square for this coordinate.
So this coordinate is 00, and zero, and 00,
and zero, so we'll just draw a square here.
And again, you're going to have to excuse my poor
square drawing prowess. And since we continue with
K until K is no longer less than n, we're going to
continue to iterate through this for loop. So to
help you guys out, I can just tell, I can just
write I right now is equal to zero, J right now
is equal to zero and K. It was equal to zero,
but we just do the square for K at zero. So now K
is going to iterate it's going to increment one.
So K is now going to be equal to one. So when k
is at one, and j is at zero, and is at zero, so
i j. k is at one, then we're going to go up
another square and this is going to be kind of
hard to see because I'm literally trying to
draw three dimensional space Whereas here
and I'm just like terrible at drawing,
I'll do my best. Give that one more go.
Okay, so once we do that k increments one,
so K is now two, two is here, and then
i and j are still zero, so we're still going to
be at j here. So we're still going to be in this
section. So we'll draw another two dimensional
square here. I mean, two dimensional cube, excuse
me, if I call a cube square, that's definitely
not right cube. So there's another cube. And of
course, K is going to increment again. So then K
is going to become three. And then at three here,
we'll drill another square, I mean, cube, sorry.
And at this point, K is going to increment.
And then it's going to be equal to four. And
once k is equal to 4k is no longer less than n,
because n is also four. So now k is equal
to n. So this world is done. And now we
move up to this for loop. And this for loop will
increment one and j will then be equal to one,
because for each iteration of this for loop, we
go through the entirety of this for loop. So we've
gone through the entirety of this for loop. So
now we can move up one iteration in this for loop.
And we can't move back up to this for loop until
we iterate through everything within this for
loop. So we're still on so we're only incrementing
the row and then we're going back into iterating
K. So now that j is equal to one is still zero, so
we're still here, we're still here, because this
is the column and then I still zero, this is I and
I still had zero. And we're still here, but j went
from zero to one. So now we're here. So we're back
into k, and k is going to start off zero again.
So at I being zero, J being one
and K being zero, because zero,
okay, this is K, and this is zero.
And we're here we'll draw a square.
Sorry, once again, I said square Yeah, we'll
draw q 10k increments. We'll draw another cube.
And then k increments, and we draw another cube.
And then k increments.
Individual one more Q, because
once k reaches four, so yeah, K, okay, we'll
increment one more time, and it'll reach four.
And now K is no longer less than in. So we go back
up to RJ for loop, and that will increment one.
So this one will now become two. And it's pretty
much the same thing. Throughout the entire
throughout the entire function, and it's
getting hard to see the cubes that I'm
drawing here. But eventually, we'll
get to a point where the entire cube
is filled in, which will look something like this.
So we'll get to a point where the entirety of this
cube would be filled with these miniature cubes,
which are just the iterations of these
four loops. So once we get to that point,
and thank you cube is completely filled in. At
that point, that means that we have iterated
through the entirety of this top level for loop.
And feel free to take the time to try and draw
this out on your own. But I basically went through
as much as I could with the time that I have in
this video, but it's pretty much the same thing
until the entirety of the cube is filled. So once
all these four loops have completed, you'll
be left with the cube that looks like this.
And since this is a cube, that means that
its height, and its length, and its width,
are all going to be of the same length. And
that is to say that they're all going to be in
because if you look here we
went through in iterations of J.
We went through iterations of AI
And we went through in iterations
of K. And again, I'm sorry, for my poor drawing,
I hope that you get the idea. So if n is four,
this is going to be four, this is going
to be four, and this is going to be four.
And to get the volume of this cube, to get
the volume, the space within this cube,
since we know that all of these are going to
be the same, we only need to know one of them.
And one of them to get the volume we just do
for this case for cube, and four cubed is 64.
And that will be the volume of this cube, which
just means that there are 64 of those of these
miniature cubes within this larger cube. And
that's the volume. So O of n cubed, r n is four.
So o of four cube, which equals 64,
which is the volume of this cube.
which also happens to be the number of times
we would perform this function console log the
coordinates, but in our
case, we just do the squares.
And that is why this function is O of n cube
must first understand what a logarithm is.
Simply put a logarithm is the power that a number
needs to be raised to to get some other number.
I know that doesn't make much sense out of
context, but don't worry, I've got you covered.
Let's take the number eight into consideration.
So we want to raise some number to some power to
get a PhD. In computer science unless specified
otherwise, we can always assume that the number
that we want to raise to sum power is two. So
let's rewrite this. So we want to raise two to
some power to get eight. So this same equation
can be written like this, or this two here is
called the base. And let's not forget that
in computer science, the base is always two.
So to find the answer to this, we
just need to find the answer to this.
With that in mind, we can see that if
we raise two to the power of three,
we get the number that we're looking for
eight, so log base two of eight is three.
So with all of that in mind, let's move on to the
meaning of Oh login. For this portion, we will
be using a very bare bones recursive function to
visualize Oh login, but don't worry, I will walk
you through every step. Just stay with me. So we
will start with a number and we will use eight so
that you can easily see how this relates to our
explanation of logarithms in the previous slide.
So this variable in we will be passing to
our recursive function that looks like this.
So this functions time complexity is Oh, log
in, let's dig deeper to find out why. For now,
let's just ignore this first line and focus
on what the function is actually doing.
So when we pass a number into this function,
it divides in by two or splits it in half,
and then calls itself with the
new half or divided number.
Let's visualize this using the graph. So we first
call the function with the value eight, this
eight is then divided by two. The function then
takes the result of the division and passes it
recursively to itself as the new value for n which
in turn results in us going one level deeper.
We then do the same thing with
our new value for n which is four,
that four is divided by two resulting in a new n.
And the function then passes our new value for n
to a recursive call to itself again,
resulting in us going one more level deeper.
We then do the same thing with our
most recent value for n which is two,
we divide it by two and the function
once again recursively calls itself
at this level we will stop is we can no longer
divide in without getting fractions as the result.
Now we have arrived at the beginning of
the secret to understanding Oh login,
so watch closely. If you look at our graph, you
will see that we've gone one to three levels deep.
If you recall from our previous slide, the
log base two of eight is three. Our input
in is eight and we've gone three levels
deep. You will also notice that we have
to raise two to the power of three or multiply
Two times two times two to get eight. And since
division is just the inverse of multiplication,
we can see that when we do something like this.
So that means that this function has a time
complexity of Oh, login. Why? Because our n
is eight. And in computer science, our base
is always two. And we must have our n three
times or go three levels deep in our recursive
function to get to a point where we can no longer
reasonably have our input in, which is another way
of saying that log base two of eight equals three.
And that, ladies and gentlemen, is the secret
to understanding Oh, login time complexity.
And as a quick note, this is not only
applicable to recursive functions.
And if you're curious about that line
of code that we covered up earlier,
all it does is make sure we stopped dividing in
when n becomes one or otherwise, the function
would keep dividing fraction after fraction until
we eventually exceed the maximum call stack.
So we'll start with a very simple function, which
contains only a while loop that assigns a new
value to the variable in for each iteration. And
for this example, let's imagine that we're passing
the value eight two hour in for this function. So
that means we'll iterate through this while loop
as long as eight is greater than one. And
for each iteration of this while loop,
we're going to divide our n by two and reassign
it to n. So our n is going to be halved for each
iteration. So currently, our n is equal to
eight, because we passed in eight as in and
while n is greater than one, we're going
to iterate. So right now is eight, which
is greater than one. So we'll do this math dot
floor n divided by two for our first iteration,
which would set our n equal to eight divided by
two, which is four. And this math dot floor, all
it does is it floors the result of our division.
So for example, if we have math dot floor,
five divided by two, we would get two here,
instead of 2.5. So after this first iteration,
our in is now equal to four. So while
n is greater than one, we're going to
do another iteration. So four is greater
than one, so we're going to do this again.
And n is going to equal four divided by two,
which is going to equal two. So now our n is
equal to two. And while n is greater than one,
we're going to do this again. So in is currently
greater than one, two is greater than one. So
we're going to do it again for third iteration.
So in is going to equal two divided by two, which
is going to equal one. So at this point, our n
is equal to one. And we're going to go to this
condition here again. So while in is greater than
one, we're going to do this. But right now n is
equal to one, it's no longer greater than one. So
we're not going to continue with this while
loop. So why is this function of login,
so our n is eight. So that means
that this function should be o of log
eight. And if you remember from the previous
video on old login complexity, this is just
the same thing as o of log base two, eight, which
just means what power do we need to raise to buy
to get eight. And if we write this out, what power
do we need to raise to buy to get eight, we see
that we need to raise two to the third power to
get eight, because two times two times two equals
eight. So this three is what's important, because
division is just the inverse of multiplication.
So if we need to multiply two times two times
two to get eight, then we should also be able
to divide eight by two three times to get one. So
there's 123. So that means that for this function,
when we pass in a value for n, we're always
going to need to divide this value in By to
log in times before we can get one, which is
just another way of saying that when we pass
into this function, we're going to
iterate through this while loop,
log in iterations, before we get to the value
one. So if you see here we have one iteration,
two iterations, three iterations. So there's
three iterations here. So this is this three
is log in iterations. Because again, oh, all log
in, just means Oh, log base two of eight. Because
our n is a, n, log base two of eight is three,
because two to the power of three equals eight,
which is our n. And that is why this non
recursive function is oh log in, because
there will be log in iterations 123. Before
this while loop ends. I hope that makes sense.
To start, we should understand that in order for
binary search to work, the array that you were
searching must be an ordered array, both ascending
and descending order two arrays will work.
Let's start by visualizing our array. In practice,
this is much more useful as the size of an
array becomes much larger, but we will stick
with an array containing nine elements to
help us understand the concept more clearly.
So let's assume that we want to check our array to
see if the value 100 exists inside of the array.
The naive solution would be to iterate
through each element of the array
checking to see if the value is equal
to 100, like so. But for this method,
we have to iterate through every element in the
array up until the value that we're looking for.
What if we have to do this for an array containing
1000, or 100,000, or even a million elements.
This is where something like binary search
can be useful. So let's try this again.
So here, we're still wanting to check
to see if the value 100 is in our array.
But this time, we'll use binary
search to figure this out.
To start, we need to find the midpoint of
our array, which is just the element in the
middle of our array, our midpoint is here.
Now since our arrays in ascending order,
we know that anything to the rate of our midpoint
will be a value that is larger than our midpoint.
And everything to the left of our midpoint
will be a value that is less than our midpoint.
So we need to figure out if this number 100,
which we are searching for is greater
than or less than our midpoint.
This will tell us which side of our array our
numbers on. So if we simply write out 43 is
less than 100, we can actually see that the side
of the array that our numbers on is this side.
To paint a full picture, let's for one second
pretend that the number we are searching for is
two and not 100. In this case, two would be less
than our midpoint 43. Therefore, it will be on the
left side. And this Ladies and gentlemen, is why
binary search will only work on ordered arrays.
Because without the order, there would be no way
to tell which side the number we're searching for
is on by comparing it to the midpoint. Now let's
get back to the original number that we were
using for our example. So now that we know that
100 will be on the right side of our midpoint,
we can completely do away with anything to the
left of the midpoint including the midpoint.
So what we're left with is this,
what we've done is we've essentially cut the
array in half. To put this in perspective,
let's imagine that we have an array with 1
million elements and we divide it by two.
In just one step, we will have cut down the
number of elements that we would need to search by
500,000 elements as opposed to iterating through
all 1 million elements and searching that way.
And it doesn't stop here. We will now do the
exact same thing with this half of the array.
Let's remember that we are searching to see if the
number 100 exists within our array, we will first
need to find our midpoint. Now don't be confused
by the even number of elements in this array.
Although there won't be an even number of elements
on each side of our midpoint, it does not actually
matter because we actually just need to split
the array approximately in half. For example,
to find the mid and code we will do something
like divide the length of the array which is four
by two. That resulting to we would use as the
index of our mid. So let's write out the indexes
of this array remembering that arrays are zero
Meaning that the starting index will be zero.
And if we take this resulting two
and see what value it points to,
we see that our mid is 100, which is
the number that we are searching for.
So in that case, we would be
done, we have found our number.
But to prove that which one of these we choose
to use doesn't actually matter, let's explore
what would happen if the mid 54 were used is the
number that we're looking for greater than or less
than our mid 54. Our number is greater than 54. So
that means that we can get rid of the left side.
And what we're left with is an array
containing only two elements, which again,
is an even array. So we have no way of
determining which one we should choose as our mid
let's see, what would happen if we use 124 is
our maid is 124 greater than or less than 100.
It is greater than, so we can
ignore the right half of this array.
Now we're left with an array containing only
one element. So our so called midpoint can
only be this element. And this element is the
number we're searching for. So we're done here.
So as you can see, regardless of if you
have an auto array or an even array,
as long as it is ordered, the search for
element will be found if it exists in the array.
And that Ladies and gentlemen, is how binary
search actually works and why it is useful.
So let's just start by creating a file and we can
call it log in dot j s. For binary search to work,
the array that we're searching must
be in either ascending or descending
order. So you can't just have a randomly ordered
array and use binary search on it. So that's just
something to keep in mind throughout the rest
of this tutorial, our binary search function is
going to take in four arguments, it's going to
take in an array, and the array is just going
to contain integer values, which will need to be
ordered, so we will just do one through eight,
we'll also need to pass in the first index of our
array to the function, we'll just call it start.
And that's just going to be zero. And we will
need to take in the last index of our array,
which we'll just call end. And we can get
that by getting the length of the array
and subtracting one from it. The reason
we need to subtract one from the length of
the array is because the index is of the array
are actually zero based, but the array itself,
the length is actually not zero based, it's just
going to be the number of elements in the array.
So the array length is going to be eight, but
the last index of the array of length eight
will be seven. So that's why we subtract the one.
And then last but not least, we'll need to take in
a target value, which is the value that we're
searching for. And we're going to just search
for eight. And then we can start building our
function. And we'll just call it binary search.
And it'll take in the array
start at the end and the target.
And this function is actually going
to be a recursive function. So to
start this function off, we need to
find the middle index of our array.
So you'll notice that we're using a
built in function math dot floor here.
And the reason we're using this is
because if we go to the definition,
it says that it returns the greatest integer
less than or equal to its numeric argument,
which basically just means that if this the
division expression within our parentheses,
within our function, parentheses return something
like 5.5, the value assigned to MIT would only
be five, because we don't want to take into
consideration anything after the decimal point
because we just want to find an index, which
of course there wouldn't be an index 5.5. So
therefore, our mid would just be five. And
the next thing we would want to do is check
to see if our midpoint is actually the number
that we're searching for, which is our target.
So this would basically return true if the mid
value of our array is actually the target that
we're looking for. So we're returning true because
that means that the value that we're searching for
exists within the array, and we would be done
here. And actually, I just realized I might
actually be confusing you guys by referring to
our mid and our mid value interchangeably. So this
mid here is actually the index of our mid which
we're trying to get we're trying to get the index.
so here we can just add index as well. So when I
say our mid, I'm actually referring to the valley
So we actually want to return true if the value
that's at our mid index is equal to our target
value. So if the value at our mid index is not
equal to our target, we then want to go on to
check to see if the value at our mid index is
greater than or less than our actual target. So
actually, this should be made index.
Sorry about that. And actually,
we have another error here. So we'll start and
then target should be here. That should work.
So yeah, let's take the time to understand
what's happening in this line of code here.
So if the value at mid is greater than our target,
then that's going to mean that our target is
actually in the left side of the array. Because if
we look here, and we take into consideration that
five is going to be our mid in this situation,
in the first execution of this function,
five is going to be our mid. And if five is
greater than the number that we're searching for,
then that means number that we're searching
for is going to be in the left side,
because if five were, if the number that we're
searching for were greater than five, then it
would be in the right side of the array, because
our array is in ascending order. So this is to
check to see if the item that we're searching for
is in the left side of the array. And if it is,
what we're going to do is, we're going to pass in
our start, which is going to remain the same. So
we're going to keep the same start, which is going
to be in this case, it's going to be index zero,
and then our end is going to be mid minus one
minus one, because we're going to actually do
away with our actual current mid and actually,
well, this should be nid index as well. We only
need to assign the current mid minus one to our
in variable, because our next execution of the
function would have this as our end, and then this
as our start, and therefore we'd only be searching
1234, which we would then in turn find the mid for
1234. And then we would do the same thing. So now
what would happen if the target value that we're
searching for is greater than our mid value? Well,
let's see. So in this particular case, the target
value would be less than or mid. So that would
mean that the target value would be in on the left
side of our right. But if that were not the case,
then if our target is larger than our midpoint,
then we would do something like else return.
So we're still going to function
still going to call itself of course,
but this time, we're going to pass in the
array, the array, and instead of passing in
the original start point, we're
going to be passing in the midpoint
index plus one. And that's going to be our new
start point. And this is because we're starting
from the midpoint to the right side of the array,
because the actual value that we're looking for is
in the right side of the array, and then at
this point, our end can just stay the same,
because the end is just the end of the array. So
let's let's have a look at this again. So so let's
again, pretend that for this execution, our mid
is five and but this time, the actual value that
we're searching for is greater than our midpoint.
So that means that it can't be on this left side,
because everything on the left of our midpoint
is going to be less than because our arrays
in ascending order. So it's going to be on this
right side. And if it's greater than our midpoint,
then of course, we don't need to take five into
consideration, which is why instead of doing mid
index, and in instead of returning mid index and
end to the function, we only need to return mid
index plus one, which is going to be this index
here, it's going to be index, it's going to be
this value six at the index one index above
our actual mid. Now at this point, we're only
searching our end and our mid plus one. And we're
only searching these three elements in the array.
That's what both of these conditions cover. So
this first condition covers if the item is to the
left of our method, which is over here. And the
second one covers if the item that we're searching
for is in the right environment. And this is how
binary search works. This is why binary search
is more efficient than say linear search. Because
we don't need to check every element in the array
we can actually essentially eliminate half of
the array by knowing whether or not the item
that we're searching for is less than or greater
than The midpoint. So let's go ahead and see if
we can actually run this function and get it
to work. And I'm going to tell you right now,
we're going to try and run it twice, we're going
to try and run it searching for the actual value
that we know that's in the array. And we're going
to try and run it searching for a value that's not
in the array. And you'll see that we're missing
something in this function. So let's go ahead
and try and run it. Now to run it. Obviously, we
have to invoke the function. So we'll go binary
search. And we're going to pass in array, start
and end target. And we're going to save that.
So we will try and write it by
just using node, login dot j s.
And we broke it. Nice. Got to add in the target
here. So it caused the entire function to fail.
See it again. Okay, so let's see what
happens if we actually return the value,
I mean, console log the
return value of the function.
And we get true because eight
is found within the array. But
what you'll see here is if we search for something
that doesn't exist within the array, we're going
to break it again. So 10 does not exist. So let's
try it again. And we got maximum call stack size
exceeded, because let me show you what it means
maximum call stack size exceeded. So what we're
doing is, every time we don't meet this condition
true, we're going to call binary search again,
which is we're calling the functions recursively
calling itself again. And if we're, if we're
searching for a number that doesn't exist within
the array, binary search is basically going to
keep calling itself recursively. And there's never
going to be a point at which it stops. Even if it
doesn't find the item within the array, it's still
going to continue to recursively call itself until
eventually we reach the maximum call stack size,
which is basically you've exceeded the amount of
memory allocated to this particular application.
So to solve this issue, what we want to do is we
want to add a base condition that will stop the
function from recursively, calling itself after
it's checked the entirety of the array. So we can
do if start is greater than and then return false.
So the reason why this works is because if the
targets not in our array, it either means that
the target is larger than the largest value in
our array, or it's smaller than the smallest
value in our array. So that means our function
will keep checking our array until eventually
we get to either the largest item if the target
is larger than the largest value in the array,
or it gets to the smallest item if the target
is smaller than the smallest item in the array.
And at that point, the start and the end values
will be equal and at the point where both the
start and the end values are equal passing
our start in our into either this line,
or this line, well, in effect, make the start
greater than the end. And now we can run this
again using this tin that doesn't exist within
our array. And as you can see, we get false.
And if we even added negative here, negative
10 doesn't exist. So we get false as well.
And let's see, what else can we try. just tried to
we know two exists. And then and we get through.
So let's change this back to a to get a feel for
why this function is oh log in, let's actually
let's go ahead and create a longer array here.
So currently, our array only contains these eight
elements. And it's going to be kind of hard to get
a general understanding of the way that our input
scales with such a small array, so we can go ahead
and just just empty out our array, and we'll just
create our own array. So let's see, the trade our
own array we can just do for i equal zero, i is
less than 1024 i plus plus. And then here
for each iteration of AI, we can just do
grade up, push high. And let's
think let's actually make eye one.
And then we'll make this less than
or equal to. And then after that
we can console. log our array. And for now,
let's just comment this out. And let's see.
Okay, so at this point, we have a longer
array, which will hopefully help for you
guys to visualize how the input is scaling when I
do some console log trickery here. So yeah, so we
don't need to log this anymore. Just delete that,
actually. So we're creating a new array here.
And it's going to be an array that has elements
from one to 1024. And for the purposes of this
example, I don't want us to find the element,
I mean, the item in the array, so we're just
going to change this to something that doesn't
exist within the array. So we'll just put it like
that 100,000 does not exist within our array,
and also the end, and this is getting the end
from this current array. So we're going to need to
bring this down to after we create our full array.
So this array is empty here, and then we're
adding all of the values in this for loop and
then we get the end of the array. And the start,
of course, can still be zero because it's zero.
And also, we can go down here and delete till
the, we don't need to console log this anymore,
because we're going to do another
console log. So we're going to
execute the function here. And then here is where
we're going to try and make some magic happen.
So for each call to binary search, like each
recursive call, we want to not just recursive
call the first call for the first call. And each
recursive call, we want to log with the array
that we're searching through is looking like.
So in the beginning, it's the full array,
which we just showed when we console logged in
earlier. And then at each call to the function,
the rate is going to essentially be halved. So
it's going to look something like let's see,
console dot log will do array dot slice.
And we're going to do the start and the end.
So what that does is, it's only going to show
the parts of the race from the start to the end,
it's not going to show the full array
anymore. And let's see if that works.
so here we can do node, log in. Okay, and yeah,
that worked. So maybe I can make this smaller.
So you can see, so when I make it smaller like
this, it's kind of easy for you to see like,
well, at this point there is too long to show its
entirety. But you can still see what's happening
here. So like since the value is greater than
the left side of the array, you can see that
all these lower values are going to essentially
be eliminated, and it continues to get halved
and have an halved. And here's where you
can start to see visually what's happening
here like I can see that it's the ray is
continuing to get smaller and smaller.
To understand ovan login, we will take
this small function into consideration.
This function has a complexity of ovan login.
Let's step through this code line by line so
that we may understand what is happening here.
This function takes one argument in which for the
sake of this example will be for we then declare
another variable y which we will set equal to n,
we will get to what this variable
Y is for later. And at this point,
we have a while loop that iterates through n until
n is equal to one. For every iteration through
in this code within the while loop is run. Let's
visualize this. For the first iteration of the
while loop in starts off is four but we divide it
by two, so n is now equal to two. Then we get to
this line of code which is the start of a for
loop. This is where this variable y comes in.
The reason we declared this variable before
the start of the loop is because n is getting
divided by two for each iteration. This in
turn is reducing the size of the variable n.
But for this inner for loop we needed to iterate
through the original size of our original n.
So we stored the original end in a separate
variable. Okay, back to this inner for loop.
For each iteration of this for loop up until the
size of n we will log or print the value for I.
Once this is finished, we move on to the next
iteration of the while loop and repeat the process
going into this iteration In is now two, we
start by dividing in by two. So n is now one.
And once again, we iterate through our
inner for loop up until the size of y.
Now at this point, you will notice that our
n is now one. If we check the condition of
our while loop, we see that we only want to
iterate while n is greater than one. So the
while loop will now terminate, and the function
is finished. Now, after all is said and done,
and with everything written out, we can
see that there's a top level loop here.
And there's an inner loop for each
iteration of the top level loop.
So this is where the magic happens. So pay
close attention. For every iteration through
the top level loop, which iterates
until n is one in is divided by two.
This means that this top level loop never actually
iterates through the full size of our input
in the value for n is being split in half for each
iteration, which is why we would say that this top
level loop has a complexity of Oh login. If you
are confused about why this top level loop is Oh,
log in, let's take some time to prove it by
writing it out. So this is Oh, log in. Let's plug
in some numbers. Now if you've watched my video
on Oh, log in, you know that in computer science,
the base of a logarithm is always two unless
stated otherwise. So this can be rewritten as log
base two of four, four, because we're replacing
in with our actual input for n, which is four. And
log base two of four is two, because you need
to raise two to the power of two to get four.
And as you can see, this makes sense, because for
this top level loop, we only iterate two times.
So for this top level loop, we have log base two
of four equals two. Now we need to take a look at
what is happening in each of the two iterations
of the top level loop. For each iteration,
we loop through the full size of y, which is
the original size of n. So that means that
each of these inner loops has a complexity of
O of n, which just means that processing time
increases linearly with the size of n. Now
this is where we bring everything together.
O of n log in really just
means O of n times log in.
And if we plug in some numbers here, we get this.
Because remember, log base two of four equals two.
And if you look at our visualization, it makes
perfect sense, because for each iteration of the
top loop, we iterate through the entirety
of y, which is our original value for n.
And that, ladies and gentlemen, is
how you visualize all of in log in.
So we can start by creating a file,
let's just call it merge sort,
well then create a function,
which will also call merge sort.
The argument to this function is going to
be the array that we're looking to sort
for the first portion of this function,
we'll need to make sure that the array that
we're passing in has a length greater than one,
we will need to do this because if the array
is only if length one and there's only one
element in the array, then it is already
sorted. This will also be our base case,
as this merge sort function is going to be
a recursive function. Next, we're going to
need to split our array in half. To do this, we'll
first need to find the middle index of our array.
So with this math dot floor here does is it makes
sure that we only take into consideration the base
number from the result of the division. So for
example, if we divide a number that results in
I don't know, let's say 5.5, we wouldn't take
into consideration the number after the decimal
point. So we would only return to the variable
the number five. And this is because when taking
indexes into consideration, there is no index 5.5
or 2.2 or 1.1, there would only be an index one,
five or two. So this is why we're using math dot
floor here. And once we have the middle index of
our inputted array, we can then split the array in
half and create a separate array for the left side
and a separate array for the right side. So we can
do that by just creating a new array left array,
and then we can set left array equal to the input
array dot slice, and then the indexes are going to
be the arguments that we passed. So basically
slices from and to. So we want to slice from
the first index of our input array. And we want
to slice up until the middle index that we just
that we just got. And that's because we want the
left side of the array. So let's say for example,
the array looked like this. And we win, we went
ahead and got our middle index, which would be
something like this three here. And then we want
to create an array starting from this zero index,
up until our middle index, which
would be the left half of the array,
and then we would go ahead and do the same
thing for the right half of the array.
So we're going to actually go ahead
and do the same thing for the right
half of the array, we'll just call it right array.
And we'll do array dot slice again. But this time,
we're just going to do from the middle index
all the way until the index, the last index
of the array, and the way we get the last index
of the array is just by using array dot length.
And this here can actually be a bit confusing,
because we know that array dot length gives us
the length of the array, which is the number of
elements in the array. And we also know that array
index is zero based. So basically, if the length
of an array is five, there will only be index
0123, and four, there won't be an index five. So
here, you might be wondering how this is actually
working. And it's because actually, there's an
error. And this method method is not slicers, just
slice, but it's because this slice method slices
up to in but not including in. So basically this
end value, it's not included in the actual array,
slice, only the value before will be included.
So for example, if we have an array
that looks like that looks like this,
the end that we would use for this array would
be three, even though that there's only index 01.
And two, it will slice up until end not including
in so this is why we don't need to subtract a one
from this because if we were to subtract one from
array dot length, and use that as the last index,
or the end index that is passed to the slice
method, then we actually wouldn't get the
full array, we would only get up until this
one, but not including this one. So they were
able to only look like this in this slice. I
hope that makes sense. It's a bit confusing.
And also keep in mind that with this example
I just gave above, I'm actually not taking the
middle index into consideration. So for this
array, in particular, it would look something
like array dot slice, well, slice and there will
be zero index up until array dot length minus one.
Anyways, last but not least, for our actual emerge
cert function, what we're going to need to do
is implement the recursive portion of the
function, which is we're going to return
and bear with me, we're going to return a
helper function that we haven't created yet.
And we're going to call it merge. And
within this marriage helper function,
we're going to accept two parameters, which
is going to be the left array and the right
array. And what we're going to pass to merge is
going to be the recursive call to merge sort.
And then our left array, and we're also going to
pass in the recursive call to merge sort, and our
right array. This is going to seem a bit confusing
right now. But just bear with me, I will explain
how this is working. And I will try to make things
clear for you. But for now, we don't actually have
this merge function, so we need to go ahead and
create it. So let's go down here and create this
new helper function called marriage, which will
take in the left array, and the right array.
Oh, sorry, and it's not merger, it's merge. Now
this function is going to be the function that
actually merges the two arrays. So the way that
Merge Sort works is we use a divide and conquer
approach in which the input array is basically
halved until we have in arrays of length one, and
at that point, arrays of length one, as mentioned
above, when we created this space case, here,
an array of length one is already sorted. So to
visualize this, if we have an array, that is one,
there's only one element in this array, so
obviously, this one is going to be the first and
last element in the array. So there's no need to
sort it because there's nothing to compare it to
with. What we do in this actual merge function is
we're going to bring these sorted arrays together
and compare them and then sort those individual
one element arrays. So one thing to keep in mind
throughout the process of writing this merge
function is that this merge function is always
going to take in two already ordered arrays,
starting with the ordered arrays of length one.
So to start, we're going to To create a variable,
which is going to just be the result array,
and it's going to start off as an empty
array. So these all equals just an empty
array. And we're also going to define our base
indexes for the left array and the right array,
but could index equal zero. Now
we'll do the same thing for right.
Next, we'll create a while loop that's going
to compare the two arrays element by element.
And actually stick here, this
length. So within this while loop,
we're going to compare each element of both
arrays and whichever element is less than
the other will get added to the result array
will then increment the index of whichever
element got added to the result array because
that element no longer needs to be compared.
If you're a bit confused by this, just
bear with me, I'll actually create an
illustration for you to understand it better.
But for now, let's just write out the code.
Let's imagine that the rays that we want merged
look like this for the left array and this for
the right array. Now keep in mind that the
merge helper function merges ordered arrays,
so it will not work on unordered arrays. In
this example, we are merging two ordered arrays
of length three to show the entirety of the
functions functionality, but this will also
work for naturally sorted arrays of length one. So
for this while loop to continue, both left index
and right index need to be less than the length
of their corresponding arrays. As you can see,
these indexes are incremented, every time that
index is element is pushed to the result array.
So if we draw this out, it looks something
like this. Here are the two arrays and their
indexes. In this next line, we check to
see if the element at the left array index,
which is currently zero is less than the element
at the right right index, which is also zero.
So it's three less than one. No. So that means we
do what's in our else condition, which is push the
right array element at its current index to the
result array and increment the right array index.
And now our right array index
is one so we can move this.
And then once again, we do our comparison at
the top of the for loop is three less than
six? Yes. So we push three onto our result
array and increment our left array index.
And we can move this over as well. And
back to the top of our for loop again,
is 12 less than six? No. So we're going to
use the code in our else condition, which is
push the right array element six to the result
array and increment the right index. And again,
we will move this and now is 12 less than 15.
Yes, so we push the 12 from the left array to
the result array and then increment the left index
as well as move this arrow to the new left index.
Now is 16 less than 15? No. So we move on
to our else condition and push the 15 from
the right array to our result array
and increment the right index by one.
Now at this point, this while loop will terminate
because if you remember this while loop will only
continue if the left index is less than the
left arrays length, and the right index is less
than the right arrays length. At this point, our
right index is equal to the right arrays length.
As you've probably already noticed, there's
still a 16 left in the left array that has
not yet been pushed to the result array. But the
while loop is already complete. So what do we do?
After the while loop, we're going to add
another line of code that looks like this.
So this return is going to return a single
array that is a combination or concatenation
of three arrays the result array, a slice of
the left array and a slice of the right array.
So this slice function if we
only pass one index to it,
it will be used as the start of the slice and
will slice up until the end of the array. Let's
break this down. So if you remember from the last
slide, our result array currently looks like this.
And we're going to add to it a slice from
the left array starting from the left
index that we incremented which is two which
results in array containing only this part
And we're going to add to that a slice of the
right array starting from the right index that
we incremented, which is three, which results in
an empty array, because index three would be here.
And with all of those combined, the result being
returned is an ordered array that looks like this.
Now let's go ahead and add in the return
that we just discussed in the illustration.
And this completes our merge function. And
now that the merge function is complete,
our merge sort function is also complete. And now
we can go ahead and test this out. To test this,
we will need to create an array. And this array,
we will need to pass to our merge sort function.
And there you have it, our sorted array.
And if we take the time to go back in here
and have a look at the code, you'll see that
within this merge sort function, we're dividing
the input array into recursively, which makes
this Merge Sort portion of the function of log in.
And actually, this merge function is
all event because it needs to touch
every element within both arrays to actually sort
them. So with this merge function being old in
and the actual recursive merge
sort function being of login.
For every level up until the depth of this
recursive function, we're actually going to be
doing this merge, which is O of n. So
to get the overall time complexity,
we would just have to multiply the depth
of this recursive function by O of n,
which is O of n log in because of N log N
is just multiplying in by log in and log in,
in this case will be the depth at which
this recursive function needs to traverse.
So let's visualize this merge sort function, we'll
go through the code line by line. So let's imagine
that we have an array that looks like this. So
this array here will be our input array. So this
is the array that we're going to pass to our merge
sort function here. So this array is this array.
So the first portion of the code here, it just
checks to see if our array is greater than length
one, because an array of length one is already
sorted. So if we get an array of length one here,
we're just going to return that array
as an already sorted array. But if the
array is greater than length one, then we're
going to move on to this portion of the code.
And this portion of the code is where the divide
and conquer approach is implemented. So basically,
here, we're going to split our input array.
By getting the middle index of the array,
we're going to split it into two separate
arrays, which will look something like this.
And these individual arrays
left array and right array.
After their split, they're going to be once
again passed to the merge sort function.
Once again, we end up at this portion of the code,
because this array and this array are individually
being passed to this merge sort function.
So for each of these, we end up at this portion
of the code. And both of these arrays are
not less than length do, we have an array of
length two, and we have an array of length three.
So they're going to move on to this portion of
the code in which we use the divide and conquer
approach once again. And let's go ahead and write
that in here actually, because it's important.
So once again, we're going to
get the middle index of our array
and create a left right and a right array by
splitting the single array on its middle index.
So you will notice that this array, this array and
this array are already of length one. And as, as
we've seen here, we're going to pass these arrays
of length one to merge sort, we're going to pass
these arrays in to merge sort, and then they're
going to get to this conditional, and they're less
than length two. So we're just going to return
these rays. So for these arrays, we can stop.
But this right here is of
length two. So this array
is going to get to this portion of the
code again, and we're going to split it.
And now, these arrays are of length
one, so we can stop here as well.
So these calls to merge sort, are the same
as these calls to merge sort. But we still
haven't called merge. And what merge is
going to do is it's going to take two
already sorted arrays, and it's going to merge
them together into one single sorted array.
And what that's going to look like
is, it's going to be called here,
these results are going to be merged together
into one sorted array. So these two sorted arrays
are going to be combined and returned
here as a sorted array of length two.
And the same thing will be done
here. We're going to merge.
And these two sorted arrays are going
to be combined and returned here
as a single sorted array.
And we'll do the same here. Merge. And these
two sorted arrays are going to be combined
and returned here as a single sorted array. And
last but not least, we're going to merge here.
And these two sorted arrays
are going to be combined
and returned here as a single sorted array.
And let's not forget our
initial call to merge sort.
So that's how we can visualize
recursive merge sort.
But you're probably still wondering what
this merge function is actually doing.
So as mentioned before, this merge function
takes two already sorted arrays, and it
combines them together into one sorted array.
And that function looks something like this.
So as you can see, merge takes
in a left array and right array,
both of which are sorted, and then it will return
this result array, which is a combination of both
the left array and the right array sorted. So to
understand the time complexity of merge store,
we'll take a array and array of
length four into consideration.
So this input array will pass
to the merge sort function.
And what that call to merge sort will do
is divide the array approximately in half
and those halves will be passed
to merge sort recursively
at this point, We have our arrays of length one.
So we can't split these rays any further. And to
understand the time complexity of merge sort, we
need to understand, oh, log in. So as we know,
in computer science, so log in is the same as log,
base two in, and in this case, in is the length of
our array here, which is four. So in the
reason you need to understand login, is because
this divide and conquer approach that we're
implementing here is login. That is to say that
log base two, a four, which is our in our
n is four equals two. And that's because
two to the power of two equals four, which means
that for an array of length four, there will be
two levels to our recursive tree structure.
And we can see that here, you have level one,
and we have level two. So this is a level, and
this is a level. And for each one of these levels,
what we need to do is we need to touch every
element of n, because we need to sort them.
And in order to sort them, if you
remember from our illustration of merge,
within this merge function, the while loop within
this merge function, needs to touch each element
to compare the elements and create the merged
array. So that means that for each level,
we need to merge. And this merge function
needs to touch every element of n.
So that means that each
level is actually Oh, then.
And there are log n levels. So O of n times
log in really just means Oh, of four, because
four is our in, in is for 1234. So four is our n
times log, base two, a four. And as we seen here,
log base two, a four is actually just two times
four. So the number of elements in the array,
and the number of levels that we need to traverse,
so for every level, we need to touch in elements
in the array, which is two times four. And that's
why mergesort has a complexity of O of n log in.
So we'll start by examining this recursive
implementation of Fibonacci. So let's imagine
that we pass the number four to our fib function.
So at this point four is our value for n.
So after we call this function, we'll end up
at our first if block. And this if block just
returns zero if n equals zero, and then we move
on to a second if block in the second if block
just returns one if n equals one. So once
we pass the number four into our function,
we'll end up at this first if block. And both
of these if blocks are base cases, because
as we know, with recursive functions, we need
to have a base case so that the function doesn't
continue to call itself even after we're finished.
So we pass the four into our fib function,
and four is not equal to zero, so we don't
return zero, and four is not equal to one,
so we don't return one. So we end up here. And
what this return does is it adds together the
result of two more calls to the Fibonacci
function, this first Fibonacci function,
we're going to call with our n minus one, so four
minus one, and the second one, we're going to
call with our n minus two, so four minus two.
So let's have a look at what that looks like.
And as we can see, four minus one is just
equal to three, so this would actually just be
three. And same for here. This would
just be equal to two. So at this point,
we have to call to our favorite our Fibonacci
function. One which we're passing three is our in
and one numerator passing two is our in. So for
both of these calls, neither one of these will
Return at these IP blocks. So we'll end up back
down here again, which will look like this.
And again, we can just do
the math in the parentheses.
And let me just make this a little bit smaller.
So at this point for these three calls to the
Fibonacci function, we're going to reach our
base case, because we're passing zero for this
call. And we're going to just return zero at
that point. And we're passing one for these
two calls. And we're going to just return one at
those points. So these are going to be complete.
These ones are done. And for this function we're
passing to is our n, which isn't equal to zero
and is equal to one. So at this point, we'll
then again go down to this portion of the code.
And now these two have reached our base cases as
well. And one more time, I'll need to shrink this.
So now we'll get into the reason why
this recursive Fibonacci function is
an exponential function. First, let's start
by observing this recursive tree structure.
So as we can see, here, we have one, two and
three levels to this recursive tree structure.
So we can write that out level one, level two,
and level three. And for this first level, here,
we're calling the fib function two times.
So one, two, and for this second level,
we call our fib function four times 1234. So
this level, we make two calls to the Fibonacci
function in this level, we make four calls to
the Fibonacci function. And let's just ignore
this third level for now. And let's just focus on
these top two levels. So two here is the same as
two to the power of one and four, here's the same
as two to the power of two. And as you can see,
our exponents correlate with our levels. So
actually, if these three functions were to make
their two additional calls to recursive Fibonacci,
we would have something that looks like this. So
we have two calls here, two calls here, and
two calls here. So we'll just write this out.
So let's imagine that these are also additional
costs to the recursive Fibonacci function. And
let's just imagine that that's the case
for one second, just so that we can get
a better understanding of why this function
is of exponential time complexity. So now,
if we count the calls at this third level
to our recursive Fibonacci function,
and keep in mind that these calls won't actually
be made, only these ones will be made. But we're
just writing this out so that we can get a better
visualization of what's happening here. So if we
counted out these calls to the Fibonacci function,
it would be 12345678. So we would have eight calls
at this third level, and eight is the same as two
cube or two to the power of three. And as you see,
once again, our exponent corresponds with our
level. So that means that if our n is four,
we would go three levels deep. And at each level,
the number of calls to our Fibonacci function
increases exponentially. But you might be
wondering, since our n is four, and we stop
here, when it's two to the power of three,
as opposed to two to the power of four,
how does that result in this function being off to
to the end? Well, it's actually quite simple. So
in actuality, this Fibonacci function is O of
two to the n minus one. And if we write this out,
you can see it's o of two to the fourth
power minus one, which is just equal to O of
two to the third power, which is the same as
the number of calls made at this third level,
right. And if you remember, in bego, we ignore
constants. So if in actuality, this function is
O of two to the nth power minus one, and we
ignore the constants, that means that we're
going to ignore this minus one, which results
in the time complexity of this function being
o of two to the N. And at this point, you're
probably wondering how we're able to add these
function calls in here. And in actuality, I only
added these function calls in here to give you
guys a better visualization of what's happening at
each level and why we're considering this function
to be off to to the internet. Because it's easier
to visualize if we actually write out these
functions that we're actually not calling. And we
can do that because with bego, as we've learned,
we're only looking for an upper bound, like we're
not looking for a tight bound, we're not looking
to be very specific, we're only looking for you
can say an estimation of the worst case scenario.
So as you can see here, on this left function,
we're calling fib and then we're subtracting one
from n. And on this right one, we're calling
fib and then we're subtracting two from n.
So this right side of the tree is always going
to be shorter than this left side of the tree,
there's always going to be this empty space.
Because on this right side of the tree,
at every level, we're subtracting
two. And at this upside of the tree,
at every level, we're subtracting one. But
when we're taking bego into consideration,
we don't need to worry about this. And regardless
of what number we pass into this function,
at the bottom most level, there's always going
to be a gap on this right side. But that's okay,
because we're only looking for an upper bound.
So these are just here to help you visualize what
is actually happening and why this function is
considered to be of exponential growth. And that
is why recursive Fibonacci is of exponential
time complexity, I hope that makes sense.
We'll start with the function that will call F.
And this function will be a recursive function.
So this first portion of the code is going
to be our base case. So if the value for n
pass to this function is equal to zero,
then we're going to print these stars.
And then we're just going to return but if we
pass a value to n, that's not equal to zero, then
we will go down here to this for loop. So let's
start with an example. So let's say that we pass
the number three to our function, what will happen
first is we'll check to see if in which is three
in our case is equal to zero, which it's not. And
then we'll move on to this for loop. And what this
for loop is going to do is, for every iteration
of in, for every iteration, up until three
from zero up until three, which is our end, we're
going to recursively call this function again,
this time using our n minus one. So let's, let's
try to visualize this. So if we pass through to
this function, and we end up at this for loop,
we can write it out like this. So for each index,
up until three, but not including 3012. And the
reason we're only doing for each index 012 is
because here, I starts off at zero, and we're
going to iterate through our input value in
up until AI is no longer less than in. So
once I becomes equal to n, then we'll stop.
So if I were to be three, then we wouldn't go
through this loop again. So that's why it's 012.
And for each of these iterations, 012,
we're going to call this function again.
And that's going to look something like this.
So if you look here, we're subtracting one
from in that we're passing to the function
at each iteration of this for loop. So
if n is three here, for each of these,
n is going to be equal to two because we're
going to subtract a one for each of these.
So these are actually going to be f two. And for
each of these, we're going to do the same thing
that we did for the first call to
this function to this f function.
But this time, we'll only iterate
through indexes, zero, and one.
So each of these are their own individual calls to
this recursive function, right. And each of these
needs to have their own for loop, which
is this, this in this. So at this point,
f is two. So we're iterating up until I
is no longer less than two. So we'll have
index zero and one that we're iterating through
and for index zero and one, we're going to do
this and the same for this call to the recursive
function for index zero and one or We're going
to do this and the same for this one. And I
apologize if the writing here is getting too
small. But you'll see that this recursive tree
gets very large very quickly. So I'll actually
need to shrink this down a little bit. So that
we can have more room. So for each of these,
we're going to call the recursive
function again. But this time,
the function is being called with two minus one,
which is going to mean that our in is going to be
one. Let's make this a little
bit smaller, actually. And again,
I apologize. So at this point, our for each
is only going to happen once for index zero.
Man, this is getting really tiny.
Okay, so at this point, our F is one for all
of these calls to the recursive function,
and AI starts off as zero. And as long as i
is less than n, which is one, then we'll do
this code. And it's only going to be less than
in when it's zero, which is this one iteration.
So for each of these calls to the recursive
function, we're only going to call this function
once for this first iteration, which is zero. Now
at this point, it's going to be f one minus one.
And f one minus one is actually going to be
equal to zero. So it's going to be f zero.
So we're going to be passing
zero as our in to the function.
And it's going to be a little bit difficult to see
because it's small. But if we remember up here,
in the actual function, our base
case is if n is equal to zero,
then we're just going to console
log, and then we're going to return.
So for each one of these calls to the recursive
function, we're going to perform this code this
console log code. And then after we perform
this console log code, we're going to return
so it's going to be finished, this entire
function will be finished, because all of
these are going to return, they're going to
log the code, and then they're going to return.
And once all of these return, this entire function
is going to be complete, it's going to terminate.
So instead of writing out console log, we'll just
write that each of these functions performs log
n after the log, the function
will return. So it'll stop.
So for the last time, I'm going to need to make
this a little bit smaller. Alright, so what
we're left with when this function is finished
is we're left with this tree structure. And
this tree structure shows how many recursive
calls that we had to make to get to our base
case for each of these recursive calls. And if you
look here, I'll go ahead and circle these so that
you can see them more clearly. If you look here,
for each of these recursive calls to the function,
we had to perform this code, we
had to perform this code here
for each of these recursive calls to the function.
So at the final level, where our base case was,
we had to perform this code. And if you count
these, you'll see that this is 123456. So six
times we needed to perform this code passing three
into our function caused us to need to recall this
final recursive call to our function six times and
perform this code six times. And that number six
is our key to understanding factorial
time complexity, because if you look
here, we have oh three factorial. And the reason
why is because our n is three, right? So it's,
we're just substituting so all three factorial
right and three factors. Mario is six actually,
because to get the factorial of a number, you
just multiply every number up until that number.
And if we multiply two times one, we get
two. And if we multiply that two times three,
we get six. And, and again, we needed to execute
this console log this code, we need to execute
123456 times. And if we dig a little deeper, we'll
see the three factorial is a result of multiplying
every number up until three, which is also the
same as multiplying every number from three down
until one, which we can see if we look at how it
progresses through our tree structure. Here, we
can see the first three is passed. So first three
is passed. And then three times two is passed
three times. So times three times two is best.
And the result of three times two is six,
and six times six times one is past. So six
times 123456 times one is past. So this for
loop first passes to three times, so passes
to three times 123, which is the same as 333,
times times two, three times 123, passing two.
And when we've asked to to the function, we do
two iterations, so three times two
iterations. So we're going to do this,
we're going to iterate through this for loop of
two iterations, three times three times two, and
then three times two is going to be six, because
we do two iterations for each of these three.
So this, these iterations plus these iterations,
plus these iterations equals six iterations. And
for each of these six iterations, we're
going to pass one to the function, so six
iterations, so six times will pass one to
the function. So that's here, six times one,
six times one, and that is factorial
time complexity. I hope that makes sense.
So to understand space complexity, we'll
take this function into consideration.
And this is a recursive function, that basically
just returns a call to itself with its input in
minus one, it's going to do this until
we reach a base case where n equals zero,
and then it's going to just return and at that
point, this function will be complete. So let's go
ahead and draw with the execution of this function
would look like. So let's say that we passed the
number five to this countdown function. So with
this first call to countdown with argument five,
we'll end up at this base case. And we'll see
that our n five is not equal to zero. So we'll
move on to this part of the code, which is just
calling this function again with five minus one.
And of course, five minus one is going to
be four. And once again, we'll end up here,
and we'll call the function
again with four minus one.
And we'll continue to do this until we
pass zero as our end to the function.
And I will need to make this a little bit smaller.
And finally, we get to the call where we're
passing zero as our into the function.
At this point, if n is equal to
zero, that function will just return.
So to understand space complexity, it's actually
quite simple. So since this is a recursive
function, each one of these calls exists on the
call stack simultaneously. So that means that if
we call our countdown function with five, it's
going to then call itself with four and at this
point, this initial call still exists on the call
stack. And the same for when we call three. These
two calls still exist on the call stack, and all
the way down until we reach our base case. Every
single one of these calls still exists on the call
stack. And each one of these calls takes memory.
So each one of these calls existing on the stack,
they take up memory. And this is how we come to
an understanding of space complexity using this
recursive function as an example, because if we're
returning at this point, when we reach our base
case, that means that it means that we have 123455
calls taking up space on our call stack, and five
also happens to be our value for n. So that would
mean that this function, its space complexity is
O of n. So this function has a space complexity
of obon. So the most important thing to remember
here is that all of these recursive calls exist
on the call stack simultaneously. And each one of
them takes up memory, which is why, if we have,
if we pass in five, two as our n, we'll have
five calls existing in memory simultaneously,
which means that our space complexity is going
to be over then it's going to scale linearly with
the size of the input. So if we increase the size
of this input, the space required to execute this
function is going to scale proportionally with
the size of this input. So now that we have an
understanding of space complexity, we can get into
some common mistakes that people make with Bingo.
And the first one being that when you first
start out with Viggo, you might see a function
that looks like this that has two for loops. And
you might instinctively assume that this function
is of all of in square time complexity, because
you see that there are two for loops here. So
that must mean observe in square. But actually,
as we've learned O of n square actually means
that for each iteration, up until the size of our
input, we're going to iterate all the way through
an additional for loop up until the size of
our input. So what does it mean if we have
two for loops that aren't nested that aren't old
in square, it's actually quite simple. So we have
one for loop here, and we have another
for loop here. And as we already know,
this for loop would be O of n, time complexity.
And this one would also be O of n. So this point,
we have to all events, so that could easily be
translated to o of two in, which is just all
of two times in so two times we have all of in.
But if we remember from our previous lessons, we
ignore constants. And in this case, multiplying in
by two, two is just a constant. So we can actually
just drop this constant, in which case, this just
becomes over then. But there's one important thing
that we need to recognize here. This is all then
because we're iterating through the same input for
both of these four loops. So as long as our loops
are acting on the same input, then this would be
the resulting complexity. But there's actually
another common mistake that people make when
taking time complexity into consideration,
which is somewhat related to this mistake.
And this common mistake involves having
two separate inputs to the function.
So let's first take this two inputs add function
into consideration. So if you remember from our
last example, we only had an input, we only had
one input, which was a and the two for loops loop
through that same input. But for this one, you can
see that we have two separate inputs here. So we
have an input a, which is loop through in this top
four loop. And we have an input B, which is looped
through in this second for loop. And some people
might make the mistake of thinking that this
is the same as the last situation where the result
would be o of two in. But this is actually wrong.
Because in this particular situation, we have no
way of knowing the difference in size of both of
these inputs, like all we know is that these are
two separate inputs. So these two separate inputs
could be of either completely different sizes,
or they could be of the same size. But from our
analysis perspective, we have no idea. so in this
situation, when we have two inputs, and we have a
separate for loop for each input, we're going
to need to keep track of both of the inputs.
So in this case, the time that it would take to
loop through both these for loops is O of A plus
B, because we need to first loop through this one
up until we reach the value of a and then we need
to loop through this one up until we reach the
value of V of B and at this point, this can't
be simplified any further we need to acknowledge
the fact that both of these inputs are separate
inputs. So this would be over a plus b. And here
we have the similar situation where we have two
inputs, but this Time The four loops are nested.
And a lot of people make the mistake of saying
that this a function that looks like this is O
of n square. But that would actually be wrong as
well, because what does O of n square mean over
n square means that for every iteration of one
input, we're going to iterate through that
same exact input. But in this situation,
when we have a, we have two separate inputs. For
every iteration of one of the inputs, we're going
to iterate through the other input. So what that
means is, this is wrong. In actuality, it's o of A
times V, because again, we need to
specify that these are two different
inputs. And these inputs could be of
different sizes. And we need to make
that visible when we take our complexity into
consideration. So that is space complexity
and some common mistakes that people make with
big O notation. I hope that that makes sense.